so how does making a second prequel make
it better we had two good x-men movies
x-men 1 & 2 2 being my favorite x-men 3
was okay and Wolverine was just that was
a bad movie the one thing that was
completely consistent in quality for me
was Hugh Jackman I always thought he was
fantastic he will always be Wolverine to
me next my first class focuses on the
relationship between Erik or magneto and
Xavier or Professor X how they helped to
create the x-men team that we've seen
already in previous films and it really
delves deep into the backstory
especially of Magneto his backstory is
very crucial to this movie the fact that
it has such rich characters such good
backstories good dramatic emotional
weight to the characters you know
they're not just superheroes who are you
know impervious to everything they're
very very human that is one of the
reasons why this movie is very good this
film really feels like very realistic it
doesn't feel like your average superhero
film feels very different that it seems
more grounded in reality despite the
fact that things that are happening with
the mutants and the powers that suffer
so out of this world it seemed very in
this world the actions directed really
well by Matthew Vaughn there's a lot of
really good special effects really good
dialogue as well really the most
riveting thing from you in this film was
Magneto my word Michael Fassbender he is
so good in this film he's got so much
depth to him you actually just see his
backstory when he was a child and some
of the things that happened to him that
caused him to be kind of the way he is
acting in this film is first-rate James
McAvoy is great Rose Byrne Jennifer
Lawrence of course Michael Fassbender
lots of great acting in this movie
there's also two cameos in this film one
of them being one of my favorite cameos
of all time not going to spoil it but
look forward to that this doesn't feel
like your average Marvel soo
or film at all it seems just a lot more
gritty and I don't mean like more
violent or anything I just mean it just
seems more real it seems less like a
we're doing this for toys and for
children and you know for superhero
comic books in something just seem more
like an actual film and I really
appreciated that I had a few flaws of
that very few January Jones has
continued to prove to be a terrible
actress she was awful and unknown he's
very stoic just totally stagnant and it
was just a little too wordy a time to
thought I'd drag in a few spots but
really that's it this is a very fun
intense good summer popcorn flick and
when I say popcorn I mean it in a good
way you know I don't use that as a diss
to me that's a good thing good
performances very good writing good
dialogue good action well directed this
is definitely a return to form for the
x-men series it's you can just kind of
act like three and four it didn't happen
hopefully this will restart its own
little thing going on here I'm going to
give it three and a half out of four
stars it's one of the best films of the
year so far
and I liked it a lot more than four so
for sure to check out x-men first class
it's one of the better superior films of
recent years
[Music]